all right mate
monty uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um
i'm originally from uh city of brazil
it's um
in san angelo valley
um
tell me about your family um family um
hispanic
foster family
i was born um taken from my mother from
birth
as an incubator for about a month and
then my foster parents
picked me up on the 30 on pretty much
the 31st day or 30 days i think they
said
and i stood with them
roughly until about 13 14.
um started uh
studying in high you enjoyed
doing drugs and stuff and uh which
caused my foster parents pretty much uh
well foster praying and and probation
um
pretty much uh removed me from their
home and put me in a
um
group homes uh
like six six six six bed group homes um
they think they said pretty much they
take out they considered me
um
not um um the they don't want me in big
facilities so they always put me in
like four bedroom homes with uh
six six other residents there what they
could do you mean what they would have
is up to six people but
those are the worst places
um
why did your mom lose you
uh drugs i was born um under the
influence of a
crack or heroin and uh alcohol
i was
that was high [ __ ] i guess for what they
say
um
how would you describe your childhood
with the foster family
it was it was good um it was good it was
good up until like it was like they
treated me like their own they treated
me as if
as if i was
as if they conceived as they conceived
me and birthed me and uh
for the most part um
oh they're really good parents actually
i i thank them for the person i've grown
up to be um but you know without the
drug use and
just overall individual who i am i think
i'm a pretty decent person and
i would uh
pretty much thank them for
just for giving me a chance
they're great people beautiful people
so no rough spots in your childhood um
well
uh not at nine i was um i was molested
by a friend of the family and um
he uh uh
pretty much like uh
we [ __ ] me when i was a kid also and
it um
when he did that he [ __ ] pretty much
he ripped uh he pretty much ripped me
with me ripped me open and
had to get stitches
and i still never told them about they
they know have no clue
even after my dad pretty much found out
from some of my other siblings that he's
done some food
ended up kicking his ass right there in
the living room
all the way up all the way up to out the
house to the front yard
and that was actually the moment when i
realized that maybe we were doing
something wrong you know i mean
everything i didn't think anything that
love it i thought it was just normal
what he was doing but
after seeing my dad
kick his eyes i was just like pretty
much
like okay maybe we were doing something
wrong
after that i started learning i started
learning about
what is it that we were doing and
how bad it is really it became very
i'll say sexually curious
and
extreme appetite
became very angry very
rebellious
drugs like for sure
getting high weed as they said weed was
like it's one thing but
i was doing anything that came my way
when i was younger like once i hit 14 15
and the city of living it was just not
crack but
everything else
i'll
get high that's all that's all i would
say is get high click it
come up to me with anything and just
let's get high drugs while you left your
foster family so really um drugs drugs
is a part of the reason
and then my behavior things that i was
doing uh um
i guess while i was hired sober [ __ ] the
majority of the time
the
distilling or just sneaking out
four nights at a time
just oh or just
fighting like a lot and fighting i
thought
feeling suspended explode from schools
like the other thing to do especially
once i hit junior high
um
there's just always something something
or someone had pissed off all the time i
had a chip on my shoulder not sure where
it came from
um
uh my dad uh he had it he got to the
point where
like i respect i respect him and i i
love my dad a lot i also feared him at
one point
and
he came to um in
sixth
sixth or seventh grade gave him all my
schools he came to my cl all my classes
and he asked the um the
the teacher in the classroom
if my son
for some odd reason just drops down and
just starts doing push-ups
out of middle of nowhere please excuse
him just let him do what he's doing and
uh and he'll carry but he'll continue on
with whatever he's supposed to do when
he's done
and
the reason was because it pretty much
said if i get suspended if he gets
another call or something
on my anger though i used to get so
angry smallish things that set me off
and
boom i'm fighting or something i mean
and uh
um
my dad pretty much told me you're like i
would
pretty much i brought you into this
world i would take you out the next time
you get you get anything from school
that's negative
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
and i believed them
and i did exactly that i wouldn't
do push-ups until my arms are weak
um the push-ups would do what they would
the push-ups calm me down
maybe calm me down yeah completely like
as long as i push
and push it i'll calm me all the way
down and it'll tire me all the way out
to the point where if somebody wanted to
fight me i would probably get my ass
kicked simply because i would burn
myself all the way out
about time i was uh sick about 12 16 i
had 20 inch arms 35 centimeter chest she
was trying i was built like like an
adult
just from doing push-ups all the time
though i was dropping i was dropping
down to do positions maybe about
three or four times at a class like it's
i didn't realize how angry i was but it
also
it diffused a lot a lot a lot
of my situations it's a way of dealing
with your anger
it was a way of dealing with your anger
right
and
that went into that football
didn't like football too much but my dad
put me in mma
and i was doing much martial arts for
a couple years
and that was like pretty much my outlet
on just keeping
calm
and collective and
it worked for a while it worked for a
long while but then uh
uh
started
with my once started putting me in group
homes and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
that's when the other drugs started to
come to play cocaine or
pretty much a lot of weed and but
drinking drinking uh
now is not my thing
when i was younger
and i was the type to where i don't know
i used to say i don't get i don't drink
tits to sip like a drink to get [ __ ]
up and that was exactly what i was doing
just drinking
and
smoking weed and if somebody had
something i never liked and never tried
i was wanting to try shrooms or acid or
and i'll try to i'm trying to the
extremes
um
uh and between all that it's also
fighting uh pretty much my sexual
identity i'm not i just didn't really
know what
what direction i was heading because
after the experience with my uncle i
didn't know
really didn't know what the [ __ ] i was
supposed to do um
a lot of sex with a lot of different
people
a lot of different
types of sex gay sex straight sex
um i wouldn't say i've done it all
sexually i've not done it all but i've
done a lot
a lot a lot of things that uh
i think that i didn't even know would be
willing to do um
was it because because of drugs majority
of majority of them
or even to to this day is still somewhat
of a not possible escort possibly the
same [ __ ]
but i do sell i sell
a part of myself
for
250 dollars sometimes depending on how
much how much of a
high relative individual looks it
depends on how i price them sometimes
just get 500 an hour or 500 a session or
whatever and
and just do that it's money but i hate i
hate doing it but for some reason i can
never just not i mean just like i can oh
i always need to use it i can always use
the money
i can always use the money it doesn't
matter
but
your drug now is crystal meth
yeah christmas is just the the one that
i just couldn't everything else
tried it did it for a while donald tried
to do it for a while so so for
the
crystal where
crystal meth has a hold on man i'm not
sure what the [ __ ]
i like just that shot
smoking it does it doesn't know sort of
keeps me it keeps me off from you know
hitting being on edge but
using the needle shooting doing the shot
is it was where i'm at home at in it
just uh
it makes you extremely horny it makes me
just
all i want to do is have sex when
majority of the time it's like yes
preferences like but that preference
changes
around whatever it wants sometimes i
just want to have sex with a woman
sometimes i want to have sex with the
trans
sometimes i just want to have sex with a
a man or a twink or whatever you want to
call it um
just whatever is it that
pretty much uh
myself my options are at that present
time
i've been
i've never posted myself but i've always
had friends
or you know friends pretty much who do
who pretty much are prostitutes or
escorts and they uh
they always help me out either recommend
me or i'll get a random call from
somebody and
you know just show up at their place
take care of business and
it'll be that
i'm guessing i'm guessing the
the size the size of
the size of my penis is the main reason
why i've always been able to
charge so high
and and
got as much attention as i did because
just
people want big so
anytime people think of big they call me
or
a lot of my friends a little group that
was in
all of us were pretty big so
it was easy for us to you know share
clients or whatever
and
where do you stay now
um when i was doing all this
um i mean where are you living now now
i'm living in uh hollywood
you're on the street oh yeah well i want
to go to hollywood
you support yourself with the sex work
um i saw yeah i was so fortunate with
sex work and uh i'm a barber by trade
and um
i'm self-employed so
my clientele is scattered all over la
but um
the most part i go to i go to you
if you watch a haircut and
cut hair um you know other things
um
a hustler just anything i can pretty
much get my hands on to sell
or anything i could um um
fix and sell
or help somebody sell or
somehow so i got
various different things that i do to
make money but prostitution is
like always been the uh
you go to the the the last the last and
the last minute go to like
but more and a more um
uh the the
so it's pretty much the closest option
that i have really the easiest option
um
was a prostitute
um
how do you know i'm 34.
yeah yeah um
it's just the thing like it didn't start
bothering me but
it really doesn't really i don't care
now it's just something of times it it
takes a toll on you um
feeling like a sex slave or somebody who
oh i have sex with someone who
i'm not attracted to out like at all or
just
dirty or nasty or whatever it came to be
it's like
there's a
specific group of people very specific
group
who are infatuated
with a [ __ ]
stocky or fat black man with a [ __ ]
13 inch penis
and those people are always the ones
that
say i work the hardest with because
it's uh
you still have contact with your family
i have my prospect now um
one of my ex-girlfriends did some um
i went to jail she put me in jail for
almost two years but um in that time she
um
she managed to just pretty much rip my
foster family out of my life completely
she getting high she just
got on facebook and
text him
god knows what and which offended which
offended my parents and my brothers
and they pretty much said you're dead to
us just don't call somebody just all the
way along you know
and nothing at that so
how many days have you gone without
sleep um
i'm probably at like
four days now four days without sleep
you do that a lot
i do yeah i don't have i don't uh do
tents or
like everything i have in my is
everything i don't know i don't have
like a stash spot where i have clothes
or i normally buy my clothes every day
if i can
um
and i pretty much fall asleep down there
every day
anyway
what do you what do you worry about now
what are you afraid of i don't know what
am i first um
being stuck in this [ __ ] it's uh
you know i only say young for so long
and
a lot i've already seen uh the uh
the um
how the process pretty much started i'm
already seeing how exactly i was gonna
go for me louder i get
um
if i don't
i just don't
get it right
soon
i would think it's a depressing
lifestyle right
you